it just seemed like I wasn't getting
enough
blood to my head I was so dizzy all the
time oxygen wasn't getting places that
it needed to be and
so my brain just wasn't working
none of my family really wants to talk
about it either because it was it was it
was traumatic for all of us
fatigue chest pain digestive problems
difficulty sleeping just a few of the
symptoms experienced by people with long
covert yet these patients have at least
one thing in common an immune system
sent Haywire by the Coronavirus foreign
[Music]
I've traveled across the U.S meeting
people affected by long covered and the
experts trying to unravel exactly what
causes it and how to treat it because at
the moment
the impacts are profound Harvard
Economist David Cutler puts the cost of
long covert at 3.7 trillion dollars in
the US alone and the condition could
impair 140 million people worldwide
Lisa is one of them the 37 year old
neurologist and mother of two was
infected with covid-19 in November 2020.
worked my job as a physician I I
couldn't really be a mom I had to
basically lock myself in my room and my
husband had to take over all the
parenting duties
so it was a
a big change to go from defining
yourself as a doctor and a mom to not
having either of those Define you
anymore
Lisa's symptoms improved after months of
treatment
she says the ordeal has made her a
better doctor and taught her a few
lessons along the way
each moment you can really be like oh my
gosh this is amazing oh I get to spend
time with my kids
it's been really rewarding to you know
apply what I've been through to to my
patients so that I can help them as best
I can
like Lisa Morgan's heart was racing
months after getting covered it's due to
a blood circulation disorder known as
postural orthostatic tachycardia
syndrome or pots
the 23 year old Yale student also
noticed her energy and concentration
dwindling
the sort of decline over the course of
the semester was so gradual that I
didn't realize the degree to which that
was happening until I hit a point where
I couldn't function I noticed in the
mornings that
consistently my heart rate would be 120
122 beats per minute while brushing my
teeth my battery it doesn't really
charge past 50 or 40 percent
doctors warn Health officials of
covert's long-term effects back in 2020
scientists are still studying what
causes it to know how best to treat the
condition
Akiko iwasaki is a professor of
immunobiology at Yale School of Medicine
she says one of the challenges finding
answers stems from the diversity of
patients
we say everything is long-covered but
long covet is likely multiple different
diseases under the same umbrella if the
disease is caused by different things
the treatment should be different
diagnosis should be different right and
if we Bunch everything together it's too
complex and so we we can't even identify
the right patients for right therapy
Lisa and Morgan weren't hospitalized for
covert Akiko says they represent the
dominant group of glom covert sufferers
women aged 20 to 60 who had a mild or
asymptomatic infection but other
patients suffer symptoms related to
their critical illness
I met Kelly at her home in April hi
Kelly nice to meet you thank you
in early 2021 she spent six weeks in a
drug-induced coma after getting covered
while I was under I had the most
horrifying nightmares but I wasn't like
all the way under so reality was working
its way into into my dreams
ironically much of Kelly's impairment
relates to her treatment in the ICU
she now struggles with PTSD and
post-intensive Care syndrome
be out of here get me out of here
obviously no one's hearing me
and the trauma extends to family members
as well
Kelly's husband Jay was told it was time
for the family to say goodbye and her
mother Brenda recalls preparing Kelly's
obituary
oceans were roller coaster
and even now even
even a year and a half later it is very
difficult to talk about she's
she's doing she's doing much better
she's alive and we're so grateful for
that because it could have gone the
other way
back in April Kelly had played down her
symptoms five months later when I caught
up with Kelly and her family she
described being tormented by her PTSD
literally night and day
it's actually been getting worse yeah
with the PTSD there's a lot of anxiety
that happens
I'm 52 and
I hopefully will live until you know at
least a few more years I don't want to
spend the rest of my life like this
at least 250 000 Americans survived
about of covet severe enough to put them
in the ICU Research indicates the
majority are suffering at least some
Effect one year later while some
long-haul patients recover over time
others don't and there are no proven
remedies for them but dozens of Trials
slated for completion in the next year
may yield Clues
results of a small observational study
indicate intravenous immunoglobulin or
IVIG might offer some promise it's a
recognized treatment for small fiber
neuropathy and it's the treatment Lisa
received I'll get your stickers okay so
it took quite a while to figure out how
I could tolerate it I believe that's
what helped me recover you know it's
hard to know what would have happened
without it of course
so I'm at the Massachusetts General
Hospital about to meet Dr Ann Louise
oaklander she's a neurologist
investigating small fiber neuropathy
it's something that she's finding is
occurring commonly in Long covert
patients and I'm also going to be
enrolling as a healthy volunteer in a
clinical trial she's running yeah good
to see you soon thanks very much for
coming in and helping with our study no
problem thank you you're going to be
doing the biopsy indeed and a neurologic
examine
since that little pinch
I have before something else
skin biopsies from the leg which allows
us to look directly at the small fibers
and count them and see if there's
evidence that some of those small fibers
have become so damaged that they've gone
missing from the skin tiny little piece
covert has left a trail of disease
disruption and social and economic
distress in its wake
we're learning much about its aftermath
by analyzing patient data
Ziad al-ali is the director of the
clinical epidemiology Center at the VA
San Luis Healthcare System where he's
LED multiple studies that have reported
important early findings about long
covert
we've done an remarkable job in
developing vaccines at record time we
need to replica learned from that
success
in the long coveted research Arena
this is not one or two cases these are
you know millions of people in the US
many many more around the world affected
with with long covid
We've Only Just Begun to scratch the
surface and understanding covet's
lasting effects what's clear already is
that the consequences of this viral
disease will be vast and enduring unless
scientists find ways to mitigate them
part of living with long covid I think
for me has been about coming to accept
that I have limitations and learning to
like find my best options
be it IVIG or
something else I I do think that we will
figure out the solution and there's
millions of people suffering with it so
there's a lot of drive to figure it out
[Music]